au mis à mort
tu ne saurait imaginer combien d'oldham
ont essayé en vain de dompter si de
l'étalon mais c'est qu'avec toi que je
veux tout partager ton amour me donne
des pelles tuer la truelle de meyzieu
accepte qu êtres mav's et arrête tout de
suite tout est fini entre nous quoi mais
j'ai planifié que notre avenir notre
mariage nous ouvrons notre caveau de
famille ça va ou bien tu es complètement
personne n'a eu qu'un seul brancard et
il a duré quatorze minutes lui mais dans
mon coeur il n'en a fait vingt ans je
peux pas une bague je vous somme pas la
balle mais non je peux pas franchement
tu es trop collant voir comment chaque
boulon